hello everybody uh welcome to today's
webinar this is peter cooper from the
ncbi
so eric i'm going to turn it over to you
and we'll go ahead and start the webinar
all right thank you so much peter um
welcome everyone to uh initial
discussion of the updated pubmed
api the e-utilities for pubmed so again
as peter mentioned my name is eric
sayers i'm going to be spending a few
minutes with you this afternoon
just talking about um what's coming up
and hoping to start a conversation with
you all about uh some of these changes
and
suggestions comments questions that you
might have about them so i wanted to
start by just saying what's going on
what is happening and then start to
explain why and what
so we will be releasing what we're
calling an updated version
of the pubmed api on april 4th 2022.
the pubmed api is often called the
e-utilities or the entree utilities
been widely used for many many years
and this is now the thing that is
subject to an update what the big news
is is that the updated api is going to
return results that are now identical to
the new version of pubmed that has been
available on websites from ncbi uh since
may of 2020
and so
that is the big value here is that we're
converging some technology stacks so
that all the different ways you access
pubmed either from the web or from the
api will be consistent
uh no other databases that ncbi are
being affected by this change it is only
a pubmed change
i just want to i'd like to show this
slide just to make sure that we're all
aware about what the e-utilities are i i
suspect many of you are fully aware of
this some of you may be tuning in for
the first time to get a whiff of what's
going on with the pubmed api but the
e-utilities have been around for many
many years as an as a application
programming interface or an api to the
whole entree set of databases at ncbi
and there are around
35 of those databases pubmed is one of
them
and so we have things like esearch
e-summary efetch
e-link e-post they all do a particular
function
um e-search provides you with
ids that derive from a text query
uh e-summary gives you little record
summaries which are equivalent to the
the search results page you get on the
websites efetch gives you full data
records for pubmed that could be
abstracts it could be xml documents uh
e-link allows you to explore linkages
between for example pubmed and sequence
databases or pubmed and pmc or things
like this and e-post is a little bit
more exotic it lets you upload a set of
pubmed identifiers so that you can then
uh do other things with them uh with the
other e-utilities like a link or
download or things like this so this is
the set of resources that we're
discussing uh the e-utilities as they
apply to pubmed and as they're going to
be updated
so let me start by discussing a little
bit of the problem right and the why
like why are we bothering you know to do
a change
it's because there is currently an
inconsistency between the behavior of
web pubmed
and the e-utility e-search
and here's how you can find that and
this has been reported to us ever since
the release
and by many of you out there in the
community and this is one of the big
reasons why we're responding with this
update so i did a simple search asthma
leukotriene receptor in the current
version of pubmed i get
2325 results and i see several pm ids on
the list here
sounds great right and i also have
sorted this not by the new default
search
uh sort called best match
but by most recent
all right if i do the same equivalent
search and the same did all this
yesterday if i do the same equivalent
search in e-search which is the
e-utility api
i get
2322 results
three less than i get from the web
version of pubmed and i also don't get
the same records in the same order all
right so this record at the top
is not actually on the first page of
this of the results returned by web
pubmed it's much further down in the
list these second two records that i get
from esearch are available here the top
record returned by the web is not
returned all right in the top records by
esearch
so these are the kinds of
inconsistencies that
many of you have been reporting like why
is it different where did the record go
um i expected this record and i'm not
seeing it so this is the problem is
trying to address this inconsistency
between these two versions of pubmed
so while this appears to be a bug
uh some kind of malfunction
in fact it's two parallel systems
behaving as expected the problem is
they're two parallel systems so here's
what's happening
before we introduced
the new version of web pubmed in may of
2020
the consistent behavior
between the web and e-utility versions
of pubmed
was
allowed by the fact that there was one
set of data and one index for searching
so there was one set of pubmed data
there was one entree index and again
this is a horribly
oversimplified version
of what happens in pubmed almost
ridiculously simplified but i i hope it
will make the point i'm trying to make
the database for pubmed was indexed in
one entree index if you were a website
user you would explore that entree index
to generate your search results
if you were an api user the e-utilities
would explore and interrogate that exact
same index all right to get search
results so the search results matched
right between the two different
interfaces what happened in 2020 when we
introduced the new version of web pubmed
is that we introduced a solar index
right to support the web version of
pubmed
right so solar is another product that
index the same data
but it's a different search index
from the entree index and so the web
version of pubmed now
uses a solar index of the pubmed data
while the e-utilities are continuing to
use the older entree index
these two indices one are not updated at
the same frequency or at the same time
they are not the same index so that they
will weight different pubmed records
differently
that's why you get different search
results right because you're using two
different systems
there's many other complexities behind
the scene but that's basically what's
going on
what we want is this
and this is what's going to happen in
april
of 2022 is a reunification if you will
so now the solar index will be providing
data to the e-utilities which is also
the same index that has been providing
data to the web new web version of
pubmed so after april 4th 2022 there
will again be a consistent back-end set
of data and indices
to support delivery of pubmed content to
you
so what's going to change all right that
all sounds good right okay it'll be
consistent yay
is there a cost is there are there other
things that are going to change that as
a developer or user of the pubmed api
need to be aware of the good news is
very little is changing but i do want to
highlight the things that will be
changing as we move to the solar indices
for e-search
the big change is
that e-search will no longer be able to
explore anything beyond the first 10 000
records returned
so you'll be able to access those top
ten thousand but not beyond that
so the value of rep max for those of you
who know what that is all right which is
the maximum number of results returned
by a query like for efetch the summary
will be ten thousand or you will not be
able to go further than that you will
not be able to sum retstart which if i
want to start at the 1000th record in
the search list and go further down
deeper in that search list
i will not be able to have a sum of red
star and rep max more than ten thousand
so all of this algebra here is really
just to say i can't get record 1001
all right in the search results those
are not going to be accessible you will
be able to get the top ten thousand
that's the biggest change the other
change of course is what we've already
discussed the results will be the same
as the web all right so you'll get the
same top ten thousand records
so that's the change to e-search
e-post
and e-fetch have some minor changes that
will be happening epost also will only
accept 10 000 records
maximum per url request
this is actually
something that very few people do
to submit that many records in a single
uh request but ten thousand is now the
the hard maximum
um you can certainly do another batch of
ten thousand that's fine uh and you can
do as many of those as you want but you
can only do ten 000 at a time in one url
for efetch there is a change that i
would say is not trivial but it is a
change that affects very few users
we are not going to be
supporting the asn 1 format as a return
in the new pubmed
so the utilities will no longer return
asn 1
they will be returning xml by default
most people that we can detect
are using a rep mode for something like
at the abstract right or even the xml uh
or one of the other formats very few
users are accessing asm1 directly
it's not something that we are going to
be able to support uh in the new version
of the api
if you do have urls
that do not supply a value of rep mode
and are just using the default
that currently provides asn 1
right in the future it will provide xml
right so
for if there are
those of you who are using that default
efetch return that will change from asm1
to xml
but the really good news is that's it
that's the only thing that's changing
the history server is going to be there
and will will work uh e-link is largely
unchanged we'll just continue to work as
it will
um esummary is largely unchanged it will
continue to work as it will
and none of the urls otherwise are
changing you can use the same parameters
you can use the same syntax
all of that should generate an
equivalent result uh in the new version
the updated version of the api compared
to the current version
so what should you do what actions
should you take
as a user
so if you're a developer we would
recommend that you at least do a code
review
to see if any of your api calls may be
affected by this change
if you do have you search calls and
you're interrogating deep down in a
results list
that will no longer function as you
might expect
and the
the search results themselves will be
changing to match the new pubmed
so that might be something you want to
be aware of is that if you really are
closely monitoring the way that the the
search results come back they will
change after april 4th to match the new
pubmed
so if you have
existing databases or existing processes
there may be something you want to think
about here uh if you're using fetch
again no asn 1
if you're posting only 10 000 at a time
we are going to be providing a test
server
i don't have a specific date yet but
later this fall we will be providing a
public test server so that you can then
you know try out these updated version
of the e-utilities for pubmed and see
how they work test your code see if
anything is going to behave in a way
that you may not expect
please uh stay tuned to our blog which
i've highlighted here at ncbi insights
we will be posting there more
information about the test server and
any other updates about this as the date
uh nears
and you know if you
go home from this webinar and have other
questions or concerns or you talk about
things or think about things as like
well i had a now i need to know
something and i'm not sure i know the
answer
don't hesitate to write into info and
ncbi and we'll be happy uh talking about
that
but that's basically all i have to say
it's it's a pretty simple we hope pretty
uh you know transparent
and silent update for most of you but we
do want you to be aware uh that this is
happening give you enough advanced
notice to do some code review and make
changes
so i'm going to
pause here
and see if there's any questions or any
other kinds of comments you would like
to make
yeah hi eric this is peter thank you uh
for that presentation there are a number
of questions actually
you answered somebody asked about the
test server and i think you explained
that we will have one of those
several people asked about the 10k limit
and they want to know if there's first
of all is there any way to get more than
10k with the 10k limit from esearch is
there a pagination feature of some kind
that you could use to do that
unfortunately no
so that is one of the things that
we find very difficult to support in the
current framework um and was not
something that we could detect as a
common feature
that people were using
so we we will not be able to support
deep pagination of the e-search results
beyond ten thousand
okay and a related question is
suppose there are more than ten thousand
um records
from a particular search
will you still be able to get an
accurate count even if you don't get all
the records for all the id correct so
the count returned by esearch will be
the count of total records returned by
the search and that should match the
count you will see on the web version of
pubmed
but again you'll only be able to access
the top ten thousand
and
are there limits associated with efetch
itself if you so for example
um
people asked about returning what's the
maximum number of records that you can
return by each fetch in xml format right
so that's there's some good news here
right there is no limit but there's a
limit of 10 000
per
url
so the way that we recommend
so if you want to get all the records
down from a very large search that's
possible
using a combination of search and fetch
so you do esearch
you know you could use put the use
history equals y parameter on there so
that you search will store the history
store your entire search result in the
history so let's say there's three
million records
it'll put all of those records up on the
history and then fetch can then go get
them 10 000 at a time
and so you can up update the red start
value on efetch
in batches to loop through and retrieve
all of those records from the search
so
again this has been existing
functionality for many years in the
utilities as a way of getting down a
very large search result so you
and esearch you know by the way only
provides you with the pm ids anyway so
if you really want to get the pubmed
data
that correspond to a search that
generates a large set
that's always been supported and will be
supported through efetch or through
e-summary i mean you could pass
the history parameters use history
equals y and then pass the web
environment and query key from e-search
e-summary and then use e-summary again
10 000 at a time
to get those those e-summaries back and
then you'll be able to recover the
entire data set
i think there's there's practicalities
and in how you want to think about doing
that um in terms of like how many
records to get and how to set all that
stuff up and how not to really
you know to spam the servers too quickly
you know we always we recommend three
seconds delay you know between
i'm sorry one three three requests per
second as a maximum in general so
there's there's you know we can talk to
you about that but the way to get a big
e search result is either to use summary
or fetch
thanks eric and uh
one question actually uh cathy knies
pointed this out
remember that
that you can
if you want to do a big number in
esearch you can always limit your
search by you know do multiple searches
and use things like the year to limit
the number of records retrieved that's
right right and you could think about
you know paginating like that's a great
comment from kathy like paginating by
year
or paginating um perhaps by other by the
other parameters that you want to use
like particular keywords or things like
that to limit the search
absolutely
yeah so another question about the
comparison between the sort on the web
versus the sort in the utilities
would the sword equal relevance match
the best match short on the web with the
i guess this is with the new that that's
the case right so when we release the
new version of esearch you will be able
to have
the same sorting options that you have
on the web yes
okay i'm just looking through these a
lot of them are sort of a lot of them
are
centered around how many uh records you
can get back which we i think we've
answered adequately
um
sort of one that's kind of an aside but
i'll ask you anyway
uh he was wondering if there was ap api
access to my bibliography data in my
ncbi
to query whether certain publications
are associated with particular awards i
don't think that's going to be the case
because i think you're right that's an
interesting idea and no to my knowledge
we don't support any api access to my
bibliography content
or science cd content or anything like
that um but it's an interesting idea
uh another one uh is there a way or will
there be a way to download the search
history from the history server
so the history server will be supported
um
if by
so i'm trying to parse the question a
bit
on the web there is a view of a search
history where you can see multiple
different searches that you've done
previously
what the e-utilities do to address that
is to
again refer to each of those searches
with the query key which is the little
integer so on the web version of pubmed
you'll see a pound sign in front of the
integer like pound one pound two pound
three like okay that's that's my search
history
and so they're all of those search
histories from the point of view of the
e-utilities are associated with
something that we call the web
environment string and so the web
environment or w-e-b-e-n-v
that's the url parameter
that string
if you give that as a parameter to the
e-utility
will allow you to access all of the
different
query keys which are the integers for
all of the different searches that are
associated with that history
so you would need to know you have to
kind of keep track and do the
bookkeeping on your own if you're an
e-utility user but keep track of which
queries key is associated with which
query
string like maybe you have 10 queries
that you did in pubmed and they're going
to return esearch is going to tell you
that's query key one that's query e2
that's query key 3. you'll get that back
in the esearch xml output you'll need to
keep track of that
programmatically but you could then go
back into any of those previous queries
and access them again
using the query key and web environment
parameters and again there's no change
to that behavior that's long-supported
behavior uh in e-search
okay just looking at that question
okay so i think you answered more than
that question uh just now but that's
good
um
a very mundane kind of question but an
important one
um
someone asked when this change is
expected to go into effect and i think
you said that it'd be useful to repeat
it april 4th yeah april 4th 2022 is the
date
and if there's any change to that we
will let you know it won't be earlier
you know so that's our covenant with you
is that you know if there's some problem
that we encounter you know we could
delay it but we don't see any reason to
do that right now but april 4th is the
is the target date again we hope to have
the test server up much earlier than
that you know this fall
uh so that you can begin playing with
these new uh e-utilities and see how
they function and i i would you know
it's an interesting point peter i would
just highlight
again that you know this is not um
there's not going to be a parallel track
here between the old version of east of
the utilities and the new updated
version on april 4th it just switches on
that day to the new version so you will
not be able to access
the old entree index uh after the new
version are released right but up to
that time you can use the new version on
the test server once that becomes
readable yeah
yes
okay so is there some specific questions
about like how to formulate
e-utilities queries that i think are
really not
um
things that we can address in this
particular webinar
um so i'm not going to really do this
but i will answer those in the
when i posted the document for the q a
because it was a little too specific
um
a couple of other questions
about one of them is about the um api
keys and and whether they will work in
both
environment
the new and the old
yes there's there's no change to the no
change the function of the api keys at
all
so if you're using them keep using them
you don't need a new api key you don't
need to lift a finger you know regarding
the api keys they'll just continue to
work
also
um
well there are many changes to like i
think this question is sort of about
query
syntax like you know the field
restrictions and things like that for um
esearch that is that different between
the two
i don't really know if it's different
between the two versions of pubmed i
hate to say no this is it's actually a
good point and it was um
an interesting point of conversation
when the new web version of pubmed uh
came out in in in 2020
but um the new solar index does does not
natively support the old entree query
syntax but we added that support in
so the new version of web pubmed
supports all of the query the open
square bracket closed square bracket
kinds of field delimiters that the
entree indexes were built on
and so for those of you who know and
love and are very you know accustomed to
using the power of those fields and
those limitations
that works on the new pubmed that was
important to many users that that
functionality continue
uh that will continue to work with the
e-utilities again so e-search passes
will pass the same query that you can do
on the web back to the solar solar index
that currently is supporting the web
pubmed so the easy test for you if you
can go to the web version of pubmed now
today
and put a query in there and get
something back that is what esearch will
return for you in april
and so it's going to be exactly the same
back ends doing exactly the same work so
it's very easy to test your queries
and again it's that i probably should
have put that on the slide as another
little action item
so if you do have queries in pubmed that
you care a lot about and you're using
esearch
try them in the web version of pubmed
now right because that's the that's the
behavior you will get from esearch in
april
okay great thank you
another question
is about edirect
so that's the the you know the set of
scripts that
access the utilities
will this affect you direct in any way
right and so um edirect will be updated
to accommodate uh the the few changes
that are happening
so in general you will be able to
continue to use edirect i think we will
have probably some additional
communications about any other details
that might affect edirect but again
edirect is a wrapper around the
e-utilities and so there's just some
minor adjustments you know to help you
handle some of the new limits to make
sure you don't go over them uh things
like that but otherwise they'll simply
point you know to the new you search and
you'll just get that data back um and so
it should be a fairly transparent change
okay also
this new the new solar
interface to
you know pubmed was an entree database
um
will the other entre parts of the entree
system be ported over to the new system
very planned right
there's no plans right now um to do
something like that um
you know there are many discussions
about the future of a variety of our
resources and you know those are those
are things that ncbi is reviewing
but there are no plans to move any other
database um to that framework um at
least in the next year or two
um we would if we were to do something
that would you know be something we
would certainly communicate um quite a
bit to the community about so this is
again something that's only relevant to
pubmed right now it has no effect on pmc
it has no effect on the bookshelf other
literature databases no effect on any of
the other ncbi resources
in terms of the api you know one thing
that comes up often is
you know is there
any move towards a restful api which
this obviously is not if it's using the
same old syntax that uh yeah that the
utilities used
it's a great question i appreciate it um
when we were
planning and thinking about uh how to
adapt to the changes in pubmed from the
point of view the apis
uh this this question did come up and we
did talk to some folks out in the
community about what would the interest
be in a restful api for pubmed um what
might be some of the ways forward there
um at the moment what i can say is this
is not a move to a restful api as it's
probably obvious to many of you after
hearing this this is simply a minor
update to the existing long-standing
interface for the e-utilities
the idea of a restful api is still being
discussed internally but there are no
immediate plans to roll anything out
like that um
but that's a conversation that you know
we'll likely be having with the
community
in the future
someone also asked about
documentation
and you pointed to the blog is there um
another place like sort of a health
document where this stuff is
the changes are right so
the main and i should have put that on
the slides too so thank you for the
bringing that up and apologies for the
omission there is a a url which is
e-u-t-i-l-s-e-utils.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
which is the long-standing uh
documentation
page for the e-utilities in general
um we will be updating those pages uh to
reflect these changes um as they as the
date uh becomes uh closer as to when
those will happen
so those pages do not talk about the
update yet um but that will be happening
okay and
there's still some confusion about that
10k results and i just want to emphasize
what eric said there is no
restriction that says you can't retrieve
more than 10 000 records you just can't
get them directly that way through
esearch so let me go back to my
slideshow here
here we are
so for those of you who are familiar
with
esearch output
what you get in the xml at the top is is
first of all a count which is simply the
total number of records returned by the
search query then you get a a set of ids
and the the set of ids is governed by
the red max and rep start parameters so
by default red max is set to 20
red start is set to zero which means
that i'm going to get the first 20
records records 0 to 19 in the list
of pubmed ids that were returned by the
search so this is long-standing behavior
so in this case there's 2322 records
returned but i'm only seeing the top 20.
so the change is
in in the current version of these
search today i could set rep max to 2322
and get 2322
ids in this xml document instead of just
20
and i could then parse that xml document
to recover all of those ids
in the future
you will be able to do that only up to
10 000 from this xml return
all right so you'll only be able to see
the pubmed ids for the top 10 000
records
so that is a change because if you did
have like a million return
i could set rep max to a million and get
a million pm ids in this xml return from
e-search today
after april 4th
that will not be possible i'll only be
able to get 10 000. if i want to get
the entire set of one million records
i can use the summary or i can use the
fetch
to retrieve those records
from the results of the search
right in batches of no more than 10 000
of the time
and so that's using the entree history
so i would set and i did not set it here
but there's a parameter use history set
value equal to y which activates
e-search to position your search results
on the entree history server
instead of just seeing this result i
will get a query key and a web
environment back from e-search those are
your tickets if you will to the entire
result set on the history server so then
i can use esummary or efetch to
interrogate that result set using the
query key and web environments provided
to me by esearch
that functionality is not changing
and is the limits of that functionality
are not changing so after april if i if
i do get a search result that's a
million or whatever huge number
i can put that research result on the
history with the search
and then query that with summary or
fetch to get all of the data
right so just somebody sort of restated
what you were saying in
the questions and let me just read you
what this person said and tell me if you
think this is right
so you cannot get pmids beyond 10k but
you can reference web environment query
key to get them using efetch by setting
red type equals uid and loop through the
red max retstart does that make sense
that's right yes you could set the yeah
efetch will return pm ids yes you can do
that if you just want the ids absolutely
use fetch
okay i think we've covered everything
that i see
there's a couple in here that are sort
of specific about querying things like i
will answer those uh in the document so
um and so please of course write to us
if there are additional questions that
you feel like you need to get an answer
to right away
you can write to us at info
ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
so thanks everybody for coming and thank
you eric for the presentation and for
answering all those questions
absolutely so thanks everybody and i'm
going to go ahead and end the webinar
for all of us